um and when we look at the average woman
who's about 170 lbs 55 um one out of
three has had an abortion one out of
four has had an STD and 90% have been on
birth control at some point in their
lives I would argue that it is not
always in men's best interest to get
married and telling men to get married
without warning them of the risks and
telling them and giving them every
opportunity to protect themselves really
is um I I would argue negligent I
believe it is NE negligent to tell Men
by and large that they should just get
married as much as I as a Catholic would
love to see The Return of families and
traditionalism I I would argue you will
never see that until you change the laws